[Music]
all right happy fourth of July I don't
know which installment this is or what
order will be going in doing different
parts on American history with David
Barton of wall builders if you're not
familiar with him he has a bunch of
artifacts here you're kind of like the
cue of American history artifacts when
we do a few different segments American
the Revolutionary War the Civil War and
today we wanted to get into the Second
Amendment so I know you have a lot of
historical documents here's some cool
old guns which I assume I can't touch no
you're walking with customers really
yeah well we love people tips in these
guns you'll regret that immediately so
let's start off with this a lot of
people have different interpretations
the Second Amendment right for example
it was only for the militia right was it
only for a militia exclusively or what
constitutes back up to to the philosophy
the philosophy was every human has a
certain set of natural rights and those
natural rights are what you find
throughout nature so when you get into
nature three things you'll find if you
start messing with an animal they will
defend their lives they will defend
their family and they will defend their
property don't care if it's a horse or a
dog or cat or mountain lion or bear so
there is a natural right of self-defense
from that they said okay every
individual has the right a god-given
natural right to defend yourself that's
something government can't regulate and
by the way you can defend yourself
individually or you can defend yourself
corporate with that kung fu when you did
this yeah okay a little Steven Seagal
actually yeah we'll just have one of my
stunt doubles walk in I learn from Chuck
Norris did you okay yeah I would imagine
that you guys are fans okay
so natural rate by the way that that's
all something you talk about quite a bit
these are not rights given by government
they're just recognized they're
recognized by government they're to be
protected by governments what the
declaration says and so that right to
self-defense can be individually or it
can be as a herd of elk or in it so I
can corporately get all my neighbors
together to defend something or I can
say I'll take care of myself I got this
so that's what the Second Amendment does
it has an individual part and it has a
corporate part I have the individual
right to self-defense and I have a
corporate right of self-defense and the
recognition was we don't care what the
danger comes from it might come from our
own government which
what happened back then it might come
from gangs in the neighborhood it might
come from a crazy neighbor or crazy
uncle so whether it's me or all of us
we've got a right to individually and
corporately do it and that's why it's
interesting they had no limitations
really on how what you could use to
defend you well I want to get into that
in a second that's also I think a quote
from Mason if I'm not mistaken he said
well why who is the militia it's the
entire people of course well here's
here's a great book this this early book
this is from Virginia this is the laws
they had in 1819 and it says if you're
16 all the way up to 45 you're the
militia every every city every town
every community 16:45 you're that
militia so that's how informal the
organization was but the law says women
were women included women were often
included but not in the law it was
people 1645 but women who was real
common to have women with arms and in
the revolution that was not an unusual
thing for a woman to carry arms so that
was pretty much they would do that okay
so we actually have a great story of
what's called the army of two in the war
of 1812 where two girls took on a
British regiment one right and so it's
great they turn that into a film and one
of them was played by Michael Cera it
was very wildly popular yeah
straight-to-dvd
so do we do we have a blu-ray whatever
it is now I have no idea so these are
the books that you said community 3 to
some example yeah I'll just read you
some example of this law and what's
required if you want to get any getting
closer you can do that too I know we're
so this is all over the state of
Virginia whatever community you live in
it's as an every citizen so enrolled to
notify show within nine months
thereafter provide himself at his own
expense with the good musket or fire
lock with a priming wire and brush a
sufficient bayonet and belt with the
cartouche box and three pounds of lead
bullets suitable to the board of his
muscular fire lock a good horn
containing one pound of powder and four
spare Flint's and she'll appear so armed
accountant provided when called out to
exercise or duty if provided there and
so they've already told you is 16 to 45
up here and now here's all the stuff you
got to help you got to be well-armed now
what if you're above the cutoff of 45
you're still well armed
no no no I matter of fact one of the one
of the fun stories of the
American Revolution as a guy named
Samuel Whittemore
and and what happened was the first
battle revolution in this Lexington the
second is Concord and so after the
British had been hit a Lexington and
Concord they start marching back to
Boston and as they're doing so they're
just shooting Americans along the way I
mean all there were 4,500 Americans
lined up along the road on the way back
to Boston shooting at them and they're
just taking everything out so the word
goes ahead of the British 700 800
British come in you guys clear your
houses because they're just taking
people down old man 80 years old Samuel
he said well not my house so he goes
inside he gets his musket he charges at
Prime's at loads as he gets two pistols
Prime's loads he's six a sword in his
belt he walks outside sees 800 British
coming at him ups with his musket shoots
one drop sit-ups with two pistols shoots
them okay so on now we're left with 797
still seems like a problem it is a
problem
he goes to Moore he kills two more at
this pistols eighty year old guy he
pulls his sword out and charges the
British one guy going at him so they
have lost three of their comrades right
there on the front line they promptly up
and shoot him right in the face square
in the face just roll and of course he
hits the ground that's it they stand
over him bayonet him 13 times then they
took the butt of the rifle and just
cracked his skull crushed his skull they
keep moving we've shown you don't wanna
mess with us the neighbors heard the
shooting over at old man Whitmore's
house and then came to look and when
they got there he's lying there in a
pool of blood reloading his guns to get
another shot off as a British relieving
he lived another 18 years living after
they they voted him in the face and
baited him 13 times 13 times and shot
him in the face butted in the face
he lived in there 18 years there's a
great tombstone to him there 98 years
old he finally dies after having been so
you didn't get rid of your guns I mean
there was no point in life or Widmore
well yeah the Candyman you say his name
three times in the mirror he's still
liable to show oh they even could be
they could live forever on the other end
you got John Quincy Adams when he's
eight years old is with the
Massachusetts Minutemen performs all the
drills does all the MUSC yourself so
Lexington green all this stuff he's out
at 8 years old getting ready for all of
that so whether you're eight or whether
you're eighty or ninety eight
matter so that kind of brings us to the
next question you hear this quite a bit
everything you just talked about muskets
or single-shot pistols a lot of people
say if the Second Amendment were written
today would be different because they
didn't take into account for example
firearms that might have had higher
capacity or were more effective do you
have any answers for those folks you
remember they had ten shot muskets
remember the muskets they used back then
what yeah I don't like well no I
remember they all said the pepperbox
revolver right yeah the buckle gun the
jeered only air deal was you have a
right to defend yourself right whatever
you have a rice so the biggest weapon
that day would have been a cannon yes it
hands down cannon you're allowed as a
citizen to own cannons yes that was the
letter of marque and reprisal - was it
from from well do you have Madison you
have all day matter of fact I was many
was it Madison well when you go back in
state laws state laws provide for it so
the founding fathers talked about it
because you know what they did is said
hey don't sit your cannon off within a
mile of town we're tired of town getting
blown up right oh this but you can have
a can't you whatever whatever the
government had you could have right and
that was the belief because we might
have to take on the government someday
we hope that never happens but in case
it does we defend ourself from anything
that comes after us whether it's from
foreign or domestic whether it's a gang
with government whether it's again a
crazy uncle right we don't care so for
them there was no limitation on what you
could use or how you can defend yourself
so if your Uncle Sam Whitmore you were
out of luck yeah he's gonna live I know
you don't have the letter of marque and
reprisal
that this was a letter that was sent to
a private ship right where you said yeah
you know of course you guys have the
right to Canada but do you have some of
the laws here that you said some I
didn't pull out the laws on the cannons
there are a number of them pretty easy
to google and search yeah and see the
town lists and actually there were some
1830 decisions where that certain town
said we're not allowing you to have
cannons we're not allowing you to have
these weapons and the Court struck it
down said you can't do that you you
can't put a limitation on how people
defend themselves it was almost sound
like like black cat laws like don't
light off the cherry bombs and fourth of
July us we're on this side of the county
line because it's more of a noise
ordinance that's right it's more of a
noise ordinance rather than controlling
it and there's fireworks they had what
they called squibs and crackers what
John Adams called him and there were
fireworks ordinances 'dump-dome in town
you keep burning down the bar and you
know quit so they were okay with cannons
okay with cannons and that was the that
would be our equivalent of high-capacity
magazines or machine guns or anything
else would take it could be equivalent
to a tank wow that is a remarkable and
yes we don't have all of those doc you
have a lot but I'm sure a lot of those
are very expensive yet a lot of them
back in the archives we've got thousands
and thousands okay but you were about to
grab something it looked like the weapon
that Mel Gibson used you're gonna have
trouble with this but I mean try hiding
these on your persons you can carry all
of these anywhere you go and these are
all American Revolution weapons so if
you want to battle axe I think that
would take your your shorts down what's
left of them you wouldn't have anything
how heavy that is that's actually how we
trim these available a lot of tire shop
comm we have some one hand axe them Wow
and this is made of what that is iron
and that is a battle hatchet that is
used in the revolution so again whatever
you have that's not a problem with that
you can have the regular Dirk knives
that's a 10 inch blade from the American
Revolution okay you can stick this in
the end of your musket and have your own
little bayonet knife and whatever these
are pistols from back in the revolution
and these are battle axes from back
there well and I can see this pistol use
it very carefully you still have to
practice good trigger discipline even if
it probably hasn't worked in hundred and
fifty years well it's it's interesting I
have a great letter here from John
Quincy Adams who talks about how his
kids are now 10 years old and I want
them trained on use of guns he says
because accidental deaths happened
because you don't know how to use guns
they don't come from from this firing
and firing the wrongs and I'm pretty
familiar with firearms wouldn't know the
first thing about how to get this to
work
do you've any functioning oh yes let me
grab one here I'm gonna grab right by
don't fire in there in the building no
we're not gonna fire it let's respect
the ordinance in here okay I saw a
Christmas story there you go so what you
get is this musket nice little 78
caliber smoothbore yeah so you see how
large it is we're not going to prime it
and set it off but what you would do you
[ __ ] it back and by the way just for
grants is two positions on this that's
half cocked okay I pulled the trigger
song can go off it looks like it's ready
to fire this is where you get don't go
off hat [ __ ] so this is what you would
have said to them don't go off
half-cocked because it's not gonna fire
okay
get all over that now what I've done is
that poured powder down here out of it
pow boy is that sort of like a safety
mechanism yes while you're loading yeah
and what happens is it's not going to
fall and create a spark and set it off
so you pull it back there while you're
loading up with powder so what you start
powder here then you drop a 70 caliber
ball ball on it then you put wadding in
cram it down so that when you go up it's
not going to roll out the end then you
go right here and you load this with
powder and there's a little hole that
goes inside you put this down on top now
you do a full [ __ ] and when I shoot this
thing watch the sparks Wow so the sparks
set the fire the ghosts inside burns
that that explodes it goes out the end
and so you got to do this every night
takes you 15 to 20 seconds to reload
every time you shoot this thing that
sounds so it takes a while which the
problem is your kill range effectively
is gonna be 30 to 40 yards and if it
takes you 15 20 seconds man a big ol NFL
lineman can cover 40 yards in six
seconds right so you're in trouble which
is why you then use the the bayonets
that went with these so now here's the
other kind of fun part how tall are you
well with the hat about six nine without
in about six - you're 60 arc George
Washington was about six two and
three-quarters so you're about how -
Washington he was exceptionally tall he
was considered to be head and shoulders
above his troops right so the average
troop is about right here you're talking
five foot one two five foot four yeah
unless you count the French
reinforcements and they're about four
foot then gas but thank you for helping
us out French we pretty good on you you
know and and that that is one time they
got the winds up so this is what they
would have done so imagine a short guy
like this having to carry this and deal
with this go 40 50 60 miles a day in a
wool uniform and carry all your stuff
with the decent were tough get an 8 2
mils today yeah so they are they're
tough guys but this is individually and
every single 16 through 45 year old who
was required by law to have one of these
have all the stuff that went with it
have enough ball and powdered the
shootin now is just only if they were
actively enrolled in the military or
pure citizen right if you're assessing
and that's similar to what they do when
in Switzerland yes that's right that is
their militia and so in Georgia for
example you're required to bring your
guns to church if you go to church and
everybody went to church you bring your
guns to church so there was there was no
kind of off-limits place in that sense
some cities tried to pass you know no
carry zones and course kept striking
them down I mean just it didn't stand up
it was a natural right and a natural
right as you said before it's not given
us by government it's recognized by
government is to be protected by gear
but like he said for some people they
might argue well this is something that
couldn't be hidden so it was all open
carry as opposed to being concealed and
they would say with go back to this go
back to this go back to these you can
hide this under you know you got those
long jackets you put that in hide it
welcome to hide but there you know one
of the differences back then was we also
had a common set of moral values and so
whether it be the Ten Commandment or
something else we have a record of one
of the founding fathers his name is is
justice Kent and James Kent is called a
father of American jurisprudence and he
talked about the crime wave that they
were having in New York he was the the
chief legal official in New York he's
the chief Supreme Court justice is
what's called the Chancellor of New York
top legal guy in the state and he said
over he was appalled that over 16 years
they had had eight murders in the state
of New York well one every other year
and that's a crime wave so you had a
sense of moral value that that was a
little different than where we are today
as opposed to Chicago with the killing
every eight hours or whatever yeah so
the difference was there was no
limitation on this because government
can't limit your right to defend
yourself what's this over here that I
see this this almost looks like a
pump-action sort it is this is we're
still 2nd amendment here and this is
from a great feminist except you don't
know where that way today says Annie
Oakley you might turn around so we can
see here could comment with your
wonderful law says Annie Oakley right
there so people know who Annie Oakley is
she was a sharpshooter and she started
shooting when she was about nine years
old by the time she was 15 she had made
so much money shooting game and selling
it to to meet Marcus that she paid off
the family morgue
she was an orphan and when was this this
would have been and she was nine years
old that's right she was without a
father for a period of time but not an
orphan that's right she had a mom but
what period in time would this have been
this would have been and yeah 1860 60s
1860 because she became really famous on
the Buffalo Bill Wild West yeah and so
this this was the kind of stuff she
would do she shoot shotguns pistols
rifles right hand left hand and she was
a sharpshooter what made her a feminist
well what made her a feminist was she
advocated for all sorts of women's
rights but you don't hear that today
because the one right she said
especially here's what makes men and
women equal the gun right if a woman can
handle a gun as well she handles a baby
there's not going to be inequality right
and so that's doesn't line up with
modern feminism but she she was the
first female superstar in a male's world
right and she I mean what she did these
are our targets that she would use in
one particular setting her husband Frank
they had a launcher it's kind of like a
skeet thrower but it would throw these
and he he threw 5,000 he's out and with
a rifle not a shotgun with a rifle she
shot four thousands of these
it seems needlessly ornate well I mean
they could just throw out like here's a
clay ball look at this that's like a
Christmas ornament that you pay a
premium for it world market this when it
blew up in front of crowd you could
really see it blow up okay and so this
is what they would use and a lot of the
shows and by the way these were made for
the French so there's a contribution of
the French for you so they've made
something we could shoot so and she was
actually on a tour of Europe in front of
the Queen this is actually a coin with
the Queen's face on it that throwing the
air and she would take and shoot through
it so you see the hole through the
middle of it I would be really intrigued
to find people that good shot today and
so this kind of goes back to the the
fact that this is in the 1800s
obviously people are talking about this
as though it's new right now that well
we don't have this problem of these many
guns today and they used to be muskets
now she was firing something obviously
significantly more advanced and people
would think of as a musket and you
really have to get to the 20th century
to sort of look at
restriction and firearm rights you have
to get to the really late 20th century I
start looking at it you know in her case
she actually offered Woodrow Wilson
World War came World War one came she
said I've trained 15,000 women snipers I
mean they can go take care of this
problem you got in Europe and he said
now I'm not quite ready for it but
that's how many women she had trained
with guns and so this was so common as a
matter of fact this we have a number of
these not Annie Oakley but these are
called Gallery guns okay and the reason
they are is that carnivals all the way
through the 1930s and 40s you would pay
a nickel and get five shots and kids
this is what they would shoot was a 22
at the shooting gallery right at the
carnival so kids are doing this all the
time and there's no big deal over it we
don't think that's a big I'm sure there
were a few accidents
well if but there probably were but they
were very rare and looking at the
founding era only found two gun
accidents at all in that era and
Jefferson told his 15 year old he said
you take a gun with you everywhere you
go
that's one of the best forms exercise
you can have John Quincy Adams says ten
year olds he says I warned them with
guns I don't want pistols and rifles and
so they trained it because the John
Quincy Adams explained that the more
familiar you are the less accident you
have right and so that's what they
really did and so and you have some
books here yeah from this is this the
physical education okay
this is a public school PE book right so
PE and this is from the all the way
through the 1970s and oh my gosh do we
have all sorts of sports here if I can
get to the front cover of this thing
yeah we've got angling and archery and
badminton and baseball and softball
basketball and bowling and field hockey
and golf and gymnastics is humbly in the
handbook and ball and lacrosse and right
here we have an entire section on
rivalry well and so this is what we're
teaching the seventies teaching kids how
to handle the rifle the parts of the
rifle all the different parts and it
also shows along with what the rifle
targets how to score target and it shows
you how to use a sling when shooting
yeah this is this is a how to use the
sling and and here was how to score the
target now would they actually shoot in
school or were they just theory here is
the interesting thing they show you how
to build a target box and this is inside
a house
22 inside a house and as they point out
we use these in gymnasiums and hallways
and cafeterias and if you want more
information in this and go to the NRA so
there's public school saying NRA is your
source on this right but in schools we
have 22s kids shooting 22s in schools
targets in hallways and cafeterias and
other place this in the 70s so this I
mean they count so you build the box and
shop and then you blow it up and exactly
right and it shows you how to how to
make it safe so all of this you know all
the different positions for shooting
standing or prone or sitting or whatever
so this is every kid let me ask you this
because we start with the the second
members we're talking about you clearly
if you go through the historical
documents it's meant for more than just
muskets right there were so that's put
to bed everyone was right constituted
the militia and now you've showed us
these different examples of people who
were very comfortable in firing firearms
in the schools up until the 70s when did
this sort of faux pas happen because it
the entire time that I've been alive
it's not been that kind of a scenario
we've always been told that you know
don't touch a firearm don't go near it
let a parent know stay away from it
you'll see a massive change in the value
system in the 60s and 70s we started
saying don't tell me what's right and
wrong and you can't tell me what's right
and wrong and we can't let in 1980 the
Supreme Court said you can't let kids
see the 10 commandments if they saw
something like don't still and don't
kill they might obey it so I mean we're
even at the point where we're taking
down what was in courthouses because
there's moral values attached to it with
that becomes an increase in lack of
self-control behavior goes the wrong
direction crime starts rising and our
our answer is don't deal with the
thinking process let's take it out of
your hands yeah and that's a crazy thing
to do I mean for me as a Christian I'll
go back to Cain and Abel they didn't
have guns so what it came to he picked
up a rock and clubbed his brother Abel
so we need Rock control laws that would
soften it I also knew someone who named
their son Abel which sort of seems like
you you're definitely a failure but we
sort of see a bell curve right like you
talk about kind of the set I would say
really the 70s 80s 90s particularly he
sort of came to a crest in the 90s the
anti-gun sentiment and now we probably
have more firearm that open carry rights
down yes down and crime has decreased
crime is
so crime 14 in the 70s and 80s if I'm
not mistaken crime crime had a high by
about 94 96 okay and so between the 60s
in the early 90s there was a six hundred
ninety four percent increase in violent
crime went through the roof right then
you start loosening up people start
saying I want to be able to defend
myself you start seeing all sorts of
laws passed for self-defense right and
the more areas where you have the more
legal guns the more self-defense you
have you know Chicago is a gun-free zone
and their murder rates through the roof
same with New York City et cetera so
where citizens have the right to defend
themselves I mean in Texas quite frankly
nobody really wants to break into a
house right because most Texans own
about 23 guns and you don't want to face
what's in those out of the door well now
what would you say to people who
compared and would you like it go I know
we have other installments we have to
get to freedom of speech and we have a
one on the Revolutionary War pre quell
kind of pretty Second Amendment what
would you say to people who say well
internationally you know we have the
worst gun crime in the world and so some
of them acknowledge everything that
you're talking about what they say we
just got it wrong because we have more
violent Morgan you know we do have more
crime but we have more freedom than
anybody in the world we have less
government than anybody else in the
world I like the fact that I can have my
own property I can use it how I wish I
don't have a 68 percent tax rate like
they do in the Scandinavian nations I
like the fact that I can decide what I'm
gonna do with my kids if I'm in Germany
and homeschool my kids I will go to jail
we have more freedoms and you know
that's that's unfortunately we don't
have the same morals we had for a number
of years you know one of the things I
look at with the Great Depression when
you have so much unemployment crime
didn't go up except in Al Capone
organized crime right because everybody
had that sense of the Good Samaritan the
Golden Rule and you know we did now
today if we had a downturn economically
today oh my gosh would be who's got the
yeah because they often say that crime
and poverty are sort of synonymous well
yeah and yeah the Great Depression
proved that that that didn't happen and
it is it is more of a heart issue in so
many ways and we we don't deal with good
neighborhoods we deal civility and
civics and and just their
responsibilities so I think that's
coming back and
I know that there is a lot more that in
certain geographic regions of the
country and you see the crime is down in
those regions
so with this less civility you see a lot
more crime and even where you you know
you have very stringent uh firearm Lars
and in San Francisco they'll just
defecate on you they're just in the
street so that ends up being a different
problem a different final question
before we end this segment and happy 4th
everybody what would you say is the
biggest misconception the number one
thing that people get wrong about the
Second Amendment it is none of the
government's business it is an innate
number right given us by God government
can recognize that it cannot regulate it
and so that's the biggest conception go
back to the Declaration read those first
hundred and twenty six Wars it's just
fourth of five principles of government
there is a God he gives you a certain
set of rights those are in a double
rights and government must protect them
in the past that you get the right to
its consent of the governed so our
decision to choose whether we want gun
control laws that's not our choice we
have the right it's a natural right to
defend ourselves I'd say that's the
biggest misconception is that government
has a right to regulate it doesn't have
a right to regulate our free speech it
doesn't have a right to regulate or
private property those are all all
inhalable rights I think that's the
biggest misconceptions we think we've
allowed government to have a role it
should never have had I think that's a
good point and I think the undergirding
history and we'll have some links to
some of the other historical documents
that I highly encourage you read because
there's obviously a lot to brush up on
the outside of just the Declaration and
the amendments well thank you so much
mr. Barton we appreciate it and there's
more if you tuned in subscribe wait I
don't know ever the but you can point
somewhere and I'm sure we'll put the
button there more to come happy fourth